Tổ như một một tham mười, tổng thống mì đúng năng tròa mặt bàn hành xong lệnh pháp,
cảm kết bảo vệ dùng mình cắt ta, nếu nước này bị tấn công.
Sáng lệnh nhiều gió, bất kỳ đòn tấn công của trang nào,
giám vào lệnh thổ, chủ quyền hay hạt tần quan trọng của cắt ta.
Sẽ được xem là mùi đezuá, trước tiếp, lùi về hoa bình và nền của Mỹ,
tương tự điều năm, giến chương, cầu trước khi ước mọi đại tây dương nato.
Thảo xong lệnh Mỹ sẽ áp lúc mọi biệt pháp đáp trả, như ngoại giao, kinh tế,
và nếu cần là cả quân sự để bảo vệ lệ của hai nước,
Washington còn yêu cầu các cơ quan của phòng và tình bảo,
phối hợp với các ta để lập kế hoa tương phó trong chương hợp hình gấp.
Đồ ha đã hoàn ngàn xa lệnh này.
Sự kẻ dễ dễ dàng chỉ vài tổng so quý ui xer an không kích nhằm vào lệnh đạo
được lượng hả mắt tải đồ ha, giới sự áp của tổng thống Mỹ đồ năng trăm.
Thủ tưởng y ser an Benjamin nên tài giao hù gả phản gọi điện xin lỗi thủ tổng các ta,
và cảm kết không tải phạm.
Các ta là nơi đặt cân cửa an ui đết,
một trong lịch có sự quân sự của Mỹ lớn nhất tại chúng đông,
và là sự chỉ huy tên phương của bộ từ đạm chúng tâm.
Dưới phân tích đánh giá đây là bước tiện đáng kế trong truy sách an ninh của Mỹ ở bùng vệch.
Tuy nhiên khắc với hợp hỏng thủ trung nato,
sớl lại bảo vệ các ta không mạng tình giang bột Mỹ lâu dài,
mà chỉ tổng tải giới thời tổng thống đồ năng trăm.